warum in ärmere länder reisen um sich
besser zu fühlen wenn man auch nach
duisburg fahren kann
[Musik]
anstatt dem klima mit einer
auslandsreise zu schaden kann man auch
dem klima im eigenen kopf schaden mit
einer reise nach duisburg
[Musik]
ich würde gerne eine reise nach duisburg
buchen dieses jahr das für mich eine
neue situation wollte ich habe sehr
selten kunden die nach duisburg muss ich
hätte gerne drei wochen eher luxuriöses
segment und gerne auch ein bisschen
strandfeeling vielleicht ein bisschen
berge und adventure vielleicht so also
vom gefühl her après ski gibt es das in
duisburg walsum verständigt
[Musik]
als schweizerin versuche ich immer auch
meine fans in der heimat anzusprechen
also duisburg im vergleich zum
rechtlichen deutschland so wird
deutschland im verglich zu beschließen
warum nach was vegas oder abu dhabi
fahren wenn man auch in duisburg bleiben
kann
so nämlich abgesehen von den
offensichtlichen gründen was kann man
denn in duisburg schönes machen
man könnte zur sechs seen platte wir
haben weder haben sich schon mal gehört
weder leipzig seenplatte ja was carla
dort machen alles möglich sich hinsetzen
kann man darum liegen uns laufen weil
das das ist auch wichtig aber das kann
man überall
ich habe eine große stärke von mir ich
habe also vielleicht zwei oder drei
flughafen in die er von mir also das
gute an duisburg ist dass man auch
schnell wieder weg ist
sie machen urlaub zu hause mit einer
kugel stracciatella haben sie geplant in
duisburg zu bleiben oder ist das jetzt
wegen der reisebeschränkungen deswegen
gehäuse geschrieben wo werden sie denn
sonst in oberhausen kommt campingplatz
wurde im westerwald
man kann über duisburg sagen was man
will aber es lädt zum träumen ein
ich finde münchen ist ja die kulinarisch
spannendste stadt deutschlands sie
kommen aus münchen ja wie empfinden sie
das ruhrgebiet kulinarisch na ja nicht
so toll also für eine kulinarische reise
reicht es nicht wenn man gern döner ist
wo kann man denn hier gut trüffel essen
trüffel was zum trinken aber wer braucht
schon schauen partys auf ibiza das wahre
leben findet in den skatepark stadt 2020
müssen wir wahrscheinlich alle in
duisburg bleiben was macht ihr wenn ihr
in duisburg den urlaub verbringt sie
besitzen jetzt zu hause nichts
großartiges machen bereits gesagt du
machen kannst wahrscheinlich weltkriegs
gucken und sagen jetzt aufschreiben oder
das wars
die akkus burg wirklich eine schöne
stadt und im gegensatz zu berlin wird
man hier wenigstens nicht verprügelt und
damit zurück ins studio
[Musik]
was meinen arsch geigensolo war doch
versprochen ihr könnt ihr in der zeit
den kanal abonnieren
[Musik]